[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt's ein Eisrezept aus 1, 2, 3, 4 Zutaten.
Es geht sehr schnell. Es ist sehr einfach.
Das Einzige, was lange dauert, ist das Einfrieren.
Das Ganze passiert ohne Eismaschine,
da ich weiß, dass viele keine Eismaschine haben,
aber ich habe auch schon Rezepte für die Eismaschine auf meinem Kanal.
- könnt ihr euch gerne einmal anschauen.
Das letzte Eis, das ich gemacht habe,
war übrigens das Kinder Pinguí-Eis.
Das kam auch echt ganz gut bei euch an.
Viele haben es auch schon nachgemacht.
Heute werde ich ein Eis mit Marzipan zubereiten,
weil ich das auch als Geschmack sehr gern mag.
Aber wenn ihr Marzipan nicht mögt,
könnt ihr natürlich auch etwas anderes nehmen.
Kommen wir gleich dazu.
Ich verwende dafür 200 g gezuckerte Kondensmilch,
200 g Sahne, 300 g Sahnejoghurt (10 % Fett)
und dann nehme ich noch 400 g Marzipan.
Hier könnt ihr jetzt entscheiden,
ob ihr Marzipan von einer Sorte nehmt oder zwei unterschiedliche Sorten.
Beim Sahnejoghurt mache ich es immer ganz gerne so,
ihr könnt auch nur Sahne nehmen und dann praktisch 400 g,
aber der bringt einfach so ein bisschen eine Säure mit rein,
ist auch schön cremig
und das lockert so diese Eismasse wieder schön auf.
Diese drei Zutaten, also gezuckerte Kondensmilch, Sahne und Joghurt,
sind praktisch die Eisgrundmasse.
Normalerweise macht man eine Eisgrundmasse mit Sahne, Eiern, Zucker.
Das Ganze wird auf dem Herd erwärmt, wird rosa abgekocht
und es ist ein bisschen aufwendiger.
Könnt ihr auch machen.
Auch dazu gibt's ein Rezept auf dem Kanal.
Aber wenn ihr sagt,
ich habe jetzt gar keine Lust drauf, etwas zu kochen
und will einfach ein Eis zubereiten und schnell einfrieren,
dann finde ich, macht man das aus diesen drei Zutaten auch ganz gut.
Diese gezuckerte Kondensmilch sorgt im Prinzip dafür,
dass das Eis cremig und eben nicht kristallin wird.
Denn das ist ja das, was wir wollen:
dass das Eis praktisch nicht so kristallig wird mit Wasserkristallen,
sondern eben schön cremig wird.
Daher eben die gezuckerte Kondensmilch.
Als Alternative dazu kann ich eigentlich echt nur anbieten,
das Ganze nach dem anderen Rezept auf dem Herd aufzukochen.
Dann hab ich hier noch Marzipan.
Und zwar haben wir hier Marzipan aus Berlin.
Das kennt ihr auch schon länger.
Das hab ich schon ganz lang, auch bei uns im Shop.
Und zwar ist das Marzipan mit einem sehr sehr hohen Mandelanteil
und dementsprechend eben auch weniger Zuckeranteil.
Da gibt's nicht nur Marzipan Rohmasse,
die praktisch aus Mandeln und Zucker besteht,
sondern auch Geschmacksmarzipan
wie Sanddorn, wie Kirsche, Amaretto usw.
So könnt ihr eben auch einen tollen Geschmack mit reinbringen.
So viel zur Theorie. Jetzt geht's in die Praxis.
Das ist jetzt echt easy,
denn ich werde einfach erst einmal alle Zutaten hier drin verrühren.
Ich habe gekleckert. [Lacht]
Ich habe nicht mehr darauf geachtet, ob der Löffel…
Haiaiai.
Also ich wollte sagen, die Sahne sollte auf jeden Fall kalt sein.
Das war noch bisschen was hiervon.
Die Sahne kurz steif schlagen
[Küchenmaschine]
und einmal wegputzen.
[Musik]
Das reicht schon. Die muss jetzt gar nicht so steif geschlagen werden.
Es reicht auch nicht… [Lacht]
Da gebe ich jetzt den Yoghurt dazu.
Tolga bringt mich zum Lachen. [Lacht]
Der Josh bringt mich im Hintergrund zum Lachen.
Ich kann da nichts dafür.
So, dann die Kondensmilch.
[Sally und Tolga bekommen einen Lachanfall]
Dann kommt jetzt die Kondensmilch dazu. [Lacht]
Ach, ich kann nicht mehr.
Es tut mir leid. Verrührt einfach alle Zutaten.
Es ist halt so:
Wenn man einmal wegen irgendeiner Sache angefangen hat zu lachen, dann ist vorbei.
Jetzt nicht so lange rühren.
Geht doch! Perfekt.
Die Eisgrundmasse ist jetzt fertig.
Und ich nehme mir jetzt eine andere Schüssel.
Ihr könnt jetzt hier 400 g von einer Sorte Marzipan reingeben
oder ihr halbiert die Masse und könnt zwei verschiedene Sorten nehmen.
Liebster Joshua, du darfst aussuchen.
JOSH: Salted Caramel, bitte.
SALLY: Salted Caramel.
JOSH: Ich bin ja nicht so der Marzipan-Fan, aber…
SALLY: Aber Salted Caramel-Fan?
JOSH: Kann man das Eis mit Nougat zubereiten?
SALLY: Das Eis kann auch mit Nougat zubereiten.
Genau, statt Marzipan könnt ihr auch Nougat verwenden.
Was könnt ihr noch nehmen?
Cookie Dough.
Habe ich sogar schon einmal gemacht, als Ben & Jerry’s Cookie Dough Eis.
Jetzt nehmt ihr einfach die Marzipanmasse und reibt sie fein.
Das geht übrigens ganz gut,
wenn sie vorher im Kühl- oder Gefrierschrank war.
Die war jetzt nicht im Kühl- oder Gefrierschrank, aber geht trotzdem.
[Musik]
Also ich habe hier zwei Sorten und halbiere jetzt hier auch die Masse.
Jetzt könnt ihr sie entweder darin verrühren
oder ihr gibt sie noch einmal kurz in die Maschine zum Rühren.
Das mit dem Messbecher war jetzt auch nur zum Halbieren der Masse.
Ihr könnt sie auch vorher abwiegen.
Aber im Prinzip wird jetzt einfach alles schön durch gerührt.
Ihr könnt hier statt Marzipan und Nougat usw.
auch z.B. zerkleinerte Kekse Zweifel dazugeben,
auch in Oreo-Eis machen.
Es ist also wirklich einfach nur ein Eisgrundrezept.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier die beiden Massen fertig.
Wie gesagt, könnt ihr euch auch nur für eine Sorte entscheiden
und habt dann eben eine Marzipan-Eissorte.
Ich hab jetzt hier Salted Caramel
und einmal dieses Pure, also pures Marzipan.
Ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich es darin machen soll.
Dann habe ich noch kurz überlegt,
ob ich vielleicht doch Eis am Stiel mache,
aber ich erinnere mich zurück an mein Eis
und das wird wahrscheinlich eine viel zu cremige Konsistenz.
D.h., es ist ein Eis, das ihr einfach ohne Eismaschine zubereitet.
Ich glaube, für Eis am Stiel reicht es nicht.
Deswegen lassen wir die Silikonform heute weg
und ich friere das Ganze einfach nur schön flach ein
und wir machen Eiskugeln daraus.
So machen wir es.
Das Eis wäre jetzt so im Prinzip auch schon fertig.
Ihr könnt das Ganze aber auch noch
ein bisschen mit Kuvertüre und Schokolade verfeinern,
sodass ihr kleine Schokoschichten habt
und darin noch wie Stracciatella in kleinen Schokostückchen endet.
Das mach ich jetzt
und nehme dafür einmal Zartbitter- und einmal Karamellkuvertüre.
Die Kuvertüre schmelzt ihr dann einfach im Impfmethodenverfahren
und zwar zwei Drittel der Kuvertüre über dem warmen Wasserbad
oder in der Mikrowelle schmelzen, herausnehmen
und dann das restliche Drittel dazugeben.
So habe ich jetzt hier schon einmal Zartbitter und Karamell vorbereitet.
Es ist ein bisschen viel, weil ich später noch etwas anderes mache.
Hier kann ich jetzt das Ganze einfüllen.
Am besten ein flaches Gefäß wählen, wo es eine schöne Fläche hat,
auf der das Eis einfach schnell einfrieren kann.
Ich habe hier einmal Salted Caramel, fülle es hier hinein.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr noch diese Caramel Crisps dazugeben.
Das ist praktisch ein Keks, der mit Karamellschokolade umhüllt ist.
Es sorgt zum einen für den Crunch
und zum anderen für einen tollen Geschmack.
Perfekt.
Sorte 1 und Sorte 2.
[Musik]
Hier gebe ich jetzt Zartbitter dazu
und hier ein paar dunkle Crisp Pearls.
Und dann kommt das Eis ins Gefrierfach
und sollte bei der dünnen Stärke innerhalb von 1-2 h gefroren sein.
Das Ganze ohne Eismaschine, ohne Rühren
und es wird, ich versprech's euch, wunderbar cremig.
[Musik und Uhr]
Mein Eis ist jetzt fertig und darf probiert werden
von dem größten Eisliebhaber, den ich kenne.
SAMIRA: Hallo. Ich hätte gerne zwei Kugeln
oder eher gesagt drei Kugeln Marzipaneis.
SALLY: 2.
Welche Sorte?
SAMIRA: Marzipan.
SALLY: Super!
Ich habe hier einmal Marzipan und einmal Marzipan mit Salted Caramel.
Ja?
SAMIRA: Ja!
SALLY: Becher oder Waffel?
SAMIRA: Waffel.
SALLY: Gut. Zwei Kugeln Eis.
Oh, das ist aber schön cremig.
SAMIRA: Oh!
SALLY: Einmal.
Oh! Bitte schön.
SAMIRA: Danke schön.
SALLY: Kriege ich sogar Geld?
Cool. Fünf Euro - steck ich direkt hier ein.
Und wie schmeckt's?
SAMIRA: Mmh!
SALLY: Darf ich auch probieren?
SAMIRA: Ja!
SALLY: Ich probiere hieraus.
Salted Caramel.
Mmh!
Und das Geniale:
Ich hatte so eine Blase im Hals. Hast du das gehört?
Das Geniale: Man hat noch Marzipanstückchen drin.
Also ich finde es echt lecker.
Wie gesagt, wenn ihr kein Marzipan-Fan seid,
könnt ihr auch andere Zutaten, die ich euch schon genannt habe,
einfach verwenden: Kekse, Nougat oder was auch immer.
Aber richtig lecker.
Also Marzipaneis werden wir definitiv öfter herstellen.
Ihr könnt ja gerne einmal schreiben,
ob ihr lieber Eis am Stiel oder Eis als Kugel mögt
und welches Eis euer Lieblingseis ist.
Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss!
SAMIRA: Tschüss!
SALLY: Falls ihr noch weitere Rezeptwünsche habt, teilt sie gerne mit mir.
SAMIRA: Kannst du es kurz nehmen?
SALLY: Ja.
Danke!
[Musik]